欢迎来到南德镇警罗沙尔斯。
Hello Hello 我是Kan。
这个老师今天我请了个朋友，也是大家非常感兴趣的一个话题就是关于茶。
那我们让他来自我介绍一下好不好。
Hello Hello 大家好，我是夏真。
每一桩圈混过三年，现在做自己的茶品牌也做了有五年了好不好。
天呐，五年了。
五年了。
我去我们认识这么多年了吗？
真的。
就35岁以后你会觉得时间被折叠了，是这样的，暴露年龄了。
我刚认识夏真的会儿，他其实还在阿富金油。
就是大家都说嘛，他是什么雕野的入世弟子之类的。
结果没想到他后来就去做了茶叶。
我也是看着他这牌子从零做起来的，也跟着他买了好多茶叶。
说句实话我不是很懂，但是一直就是我们的群友也好。
最近大家也挺多的讨论关于茶这个品类，
所以我就想着说赶紧耗夏真来聊一起。
谢谢老师你自己对茶啥感觉啊？
我妈我喝茶，但是我不懂茶。
那我们还需要夏真帮忙刻铺一下哈？
对对对，非常需要，非常需要。
现在这个茶行业，说是原业茶，
已经在2024年的时候就有三千五百亿了。
另一方面呢，我没有听到一种说法说什么，
七万家茶起不如一个立顿，
所以想知道是你怎么看这个行业呀？
现在茶品牌坏这个问题到底是不是个文明题啊？
这个行业就属于体量不小，甚至很大，
但是没有什么存在感。
它不出现在任何券商的报告里，
因为茶行业的上市公司一是数量就不多，
就一个蓝苍古茶，一个巴马，
然后这两家还还还在退市的边缘是吧？
对，特别是最近你知道我们不是在做破产系列吗？
就会有各种网友投地稿件，
然后就有人投地查理，我们说查理还没良透，
但他们说你看对比它风光的时候，
其实现在已经很难了哈。
其实七万茶起不如一个立顿，
这句话有点久了啊，这是二零零几年的话，
那个时候因为整个中国的经济体量不大，
所以当时是整个茶行业都不如一个立顿，
就中国当时整个茶行业的产值都只有三百多亿，
然后立顿全球的产值大概是三百多亿。
到目前为止中国前十个的原业茶品牌。
还是不如立顿全球的，这个事情是有的。
你看这背后意味着什么，
背后意味着是因为中国茶品牌都只做本土市场，
它其实是拿本土市场打全球市场，你肯定打不过的。
就跟以前有一段时间讨论中国和美国的票房，
那中国的电影是吃中国市场，
美国电影是吃全球市场，你肯定打不过的。
另外一个点是中国市场的问题，
中国的原业茶市场它比较讨厌和捉急，
或者是有硬伤的地方是它极度的散碎，
它本质上是1000万茶农加100万的茶旗。
我们看2020年有132万，真的很多。
那我都还说少了，这个市场主体它也碎了，
所以就是国内市场对全球市场，
然后低级中度对高级中度，
所以就会显得立顿的快头在国内这些做原业茶的品牌看来就会非常的大。
这个里面最大的问题其实是产业的问题，
刚才我们说它很碎，所以它在供给端看，
最困难的问题就是1000万茶农，100万茶店的老板这个门槛太低了。
然后就是中国农业的老毛病，
就一沾上农业就会意味着完全没有控制的去扩产的，
蓝莓的故事，阳光玫瑰的故事对吧。
就把所有价格打下来？
就我现在很怕听到注农两个字，
因为大家一谈到注农，想到的不是说我们做金品，我们做门槛，
我们像日本的农民一样去把每一个农人的头像印到它的产出上，
然后很自豪地去为它的品质做担保，
也不是说像法国的农协一样种葡萄的农民联合起来，
我们达到一个标准，
我们把它送去做小产区的葡萄酒，
达不到的标准，我们就让它去做餐酒，没有。
一沾上中国的整个农业的生产环境，那就是大干快上，
因为中国农业是包产到户的，所以它农民特别的多，特别的碎。
第三，在这个过程当中它分工还很弱，
没有人听过有人会从重小卖一直到做面包一条龙，
中间有很多生产环节，重小卖重小卖的磨面粉是磨面粉的，
做面包是做面包的，然后卖面包是卖面包的，
它每一个环节是有收回分工的，
但是在中国茶这个领域，尤其是圆圆茶这个领域，
大家还很相信茶农自己种自己做自己消。
哦，确实。
我们就看这两天央视曝光的经文就知道了嘛，
茶农直播，大家就特别信那个。
对，找了一帮演员在那种假装式茶农，
其实搞半天最后都是演的。
说到这里就是我有一个很伤心的时刻，
我们到现在都不爱干抖音，
原因就是我有一天看抖音的排行榜，
排名第一再用三百块钱，
已经卖老班张茶农地，
排名第二再用五百块钱，已经卖渔山的坑舰茶，
然后背后还放了一堆制茶能手的奖，
浙江那奖，然后五百一斤的坑舰茶。
理论上应该多少呀，给我们科普科普。
理论上应该翻个十倍左右吧。
我去，所以抖音就是把价格打下来。
关键是底下的人还真的信，
然后有一些董航的人跟他们说这个是假的，
他们还把他骂出去，说他就是韭菜，
他活该被割，然后我看完心里就卖粮卖粮的，
就是我们做再多的努力，
做再多的证明都不如几个假农民在镜头前面演一演，
你就会觉得很伤心在那个时候。
像盐茶那边的很多鲜业的价格都不止五百块，
更何况说是成品茶说五百块钱，
这个根本做不到的。
对，刚才是供几端嘛，
所以我们这里，我们就聊到需求端了，
就这个行业在需求上面的困难点，
是它的供需匹配极端困难，
不是一般的困难，是极端的困难，
因为每个茶的味道都不一样，
千茶千味，
同时每个人的风味审美，
需求也都不一样，千人千面，
你供给有一千个，
需求有一千个，
这怎么匹配啊？
就这个匹配的难度是非常大的，
所以很多和原业茶和中国茶入门的这些朋友，
他们整个入门的过程，
就是不断的尝试，不断的尝试，
最后发现这几个味道是我喜欢的，
那就把它固定下来。
它需要可能一个长达两三年的探索期，
来摸清楚自己的风味审美，
大概是什么样子的。
当然，这个过程也在筛它的供应商，
我自己当茶客的时候，
喝着喝着我发现，
哎，我不是个C端用户嘛，
我怎么感觉我在管我的供应商户呢？
就会产生这样的错觉，
这个背后的原因，
也是因为供几端是没有大品牌的，
所以消费者是很难直接说，
哦，谁就是值得信任的，我信他就可以了，
也没有人去教育市场。
对，我就感觉我的舌头。
甚至吃不出来这种十倍差距的茶，
嗯，慢慢喝，有比较的喝还是能喝出来的，
但它就是需要时间，
需要时间需要量，
就是它很像什么，
它很像，你听过杨振宁说审美的那个评价吗？
就它不是一个理性判断，
它是一个直觉洞茶，
当你在好东西里面泡久了，
你就是一下子就能把那个贵东西喝出来。
跟我学李小龙说，
对，我同意乡正老师那个说法，
因为我自己也喝茶嘛，
如果你经常喝同一种茶，
比如说我喝的比较多的是，
安吉白茶跟碧罗春，
就是好着茶跟不好着茶，
还是喝得出来的，
但是你让我去喝盐茶，
或喝无农茶，我都喝不出来了，
它是需要一个量，
而且那种好余不好，
你没办法用理性判断，
你只能说喝的那一瞬间，
你敢说这茶不错，
就是那种感觉。
风味饮品啊，
它有一点点像你们熟悉的美妆内幕里面的香水，
对，我同意。
我们把食用属性先放到一边，
我们对茶的分解，
我会认为它至少是有这么几个层面，
它的底层是功能性饮品，
它的中间层是风味饮品，
它的顶层是文化社交和精神享受，
我们把底层功能性先放到一边，
功能性也不值钱，
立顿的茶豆分含量美妆还更高，
因为它用的叶子很多都是下秋茶，
越老茶豆分越多，
风味这个东西，
没有什么倒立科匠，
它就是体验，就是纯体验，
所以这个过程就是一个用户，
从他开始喝茶到他觉得自己差不多摸到门道了，
他会经历一个漫长的探索过程，
这个过程当中还没有什么品牌引导，
基本上就靠耳濡木然家里带着喝，
然后自己摸着石头过河，
但好在我们的文化环境还不错，
比如说我们看电视剧，
东京墨华路之否里面都有喝茶的场景，
以前的大量的亲公戚，
乾隆爷下江南怎么高低都得整两倍农季，
这就是靠耳濡木然家里的氛围和。
整个社会的文化氛围来做这个品类的教育的。
而且我有一个国安厂，
因为茶叶其实属于一个农产品的粗加工嘛，
它本身不是一个精致加工产品，
所以就是这种越靠近原产地，
其实你的品牌越难做，
我为什么会有这个想法呢，
是因为我们家里人去德国煮菜，
然后就提到了说德国啤酒特别好喝，
我问他是什么牌子，
我家里人跟我这么说的，
他说是他们德国的朋友家里人酿的，
就是他们家里有一个小小的酒厂，
类似于像那种接近原产地的概念嘛，
然后后来包括我问巴西的朋友，
我问他们用巴西盛产咖啡豆嘛，
然后问他我说你们巴西人买咖啡豆怎么说，
他们说很多时候都是朋友家里的农装里面买一点，
我突然那一瞬间有种感觉，
因为本身是一个粗加工农产品，
它其实盛产的门槛比较低，
农民自己就可以解决生产的问题，
它从种植一到生产，
它可以自己解决，
我们说利顿是全球一个很大的茶叶的供应商，
那原因是因为欧洲基本就不产茶，
它的茶叶的主要来源是来自于印度和孟加拉，
这种品牌化其实是在被压制的，
因为用户的购买渠道太多了，
就像刚才小长老说的，
我们有100多万家茶企，有几千万的茶农，
就像我买的比罗春，
从来没有什么正规渠道，
苏州也有种老字号的，从来不是，
我都是打电话给我西山的朋友，
他帮我弄一点，然后我钱付给他，
完全就是这种路径，
包括像我们该买很多东西，
包括像买大达蟹也是，
都走着这种路径，
我觉得这是不是一种中国特色？
我管着叫远香尽臭，
普通的眼里没有英雄，
就距离太近了，
之前我和吉普奥的老板，
现在可能大家更熟的是，
他做的新茶饮品牌上山喝茶，
我和小黑聊过这个问题，
这个观点的版权属于小黑，
小黑认为是产区是没有品牌的，
消区才有品牌，
咖啡所有的品牌也单身于消区，
产区像非洲、南美，
其实很难说有什么品牌，
但国内市场足够大和宽阔，
比如说我们看北京的老字号，
张元、吴玉泰，
在清朝的时候，他们就是消区品牌，
他们是安徽的茶商，
他们的产气在安徽，
但他们的消区在北京，
所以张元和吴玉泰，
是在北京养民立万的，
从这个观点来看的话，
我觉得我们可能还蛮有机会的，
因为我们也不是一个茶山品牌，
我们是单身在北京的品牌，
消区品牌，
对，我们很明显是消区品牌，
说白了在供给和需求这两端，
你到底站在谁那一端？
目前来看，
我们肯定屁股是站在需求这一端的，
刚才CK老师说的言很多，
就是国内的咖啡，
就是国外的茶，
所以也许属于中国茶。
跟大的机会还是在海外，
实际上在过去的全球贸易史当中，
中国的茶叶贸易在明朝晚期到清朝最猛的时候，
占到过整个中国出口贸易量的三分之一左右。
就是那个白银战争，
南美的银子，
白花花的银子，
都流进来，
至少三分之一是换了中国的茶叶。
就是China Tea,。
主要就是两大东西。
在从传统的农业，
像工业化农业转型的过程当中，
密集种植化肥农药，
这一波其实是让率先进入到。
工业时代的世界工厂的英国，
在他们的殖民地开始以远超于。
中国的成本优势去生产茶，
其实那个时候的西兰红茶也好，
阿萨姆也好，
都是那个时候的产物，
然后英国人自己又有全球市场，
等于就是供给和市场，
他们就一把抓了。
我们有句老话叫做。
国运就是茶运，
你国运不好的时候，
中国茶也好，
中国陶瓷也好，
当时一整个都是灭顶之灾。
这个图是一直到了，
最近这十年中国茶的产销量。
才重新回到世界第一。
因为我刚好有个好朋友，
酸奶哥，
他以前就是立顿的品牌经理，
从他个人的角度来说，
他们当时是花了挺多的精力，
希望去教育整个中国的市场，
用代泡茶这个品类，
但他说就是做到头，
无论是请明星打广告，
也就不到四个点的市场份额，
就整个代泡茶占中国，
所以他最后得出的一个结论，
他感觉在中国这种。
他本身根深蒂固的环境之下，
你以快销品的逻辑做茶，
就是很受限。
他最后可能最大的生意，
还是土壁的渠道，
无论是企业的采购，
还是酒店，
这个生意体量，
他觉得很受限制。
另外一块确实就是，
他觉得外国的茶文化。
要进到中国，
其实还是相对弱势的，
所以无论是灵活度，
还是跟中文化的匹配度，
就感觉隔绝骚扬，
所以他最后还是觉得说，
立顿会退出中国，
最后就是也就卖给P一张的形式，
我觉得是没办法的，
终会有这么一天，
我不知道下阵怎么看这个品类。
主要是中国人在吃吃喝喝这件事情上，
拒绝一切别人的评价，
恩格尔恩格尔他懂吃吗？
就代泡茶最大的问题，
并不是快销，
我们也在走快销化，
实实上我觉得，
所有的饮品，
它都是快销，
它是一个按月消费，
按日去消耗的产品，
它为什么不是快销，
它肯定快销啊，
我们很多客户买茶的品次，
比买面霜快多了，
我报个数你们感受一下，
我们从二三年开始做视频号，
我现在IP号在视频号的数据，
是大概有两万多人购买，
这个数不下人，
一万多人复购，
百分之五十复购率，
这个数有点厉害，
但是也不下人，
这一万多人买了五十万单，
人均五十单，
哇去，这么快销啊，
快销不快销，
这可太高频了，
它还不是同一年，
它是三年陆陆续续获的课，
五十单，
年均多少单？
果然是个沉隐性消费，
它肯定快销啊，
屏次太高了，
这个里面的问题，
如果不再快销它在哪里，
它在于代泡茶这个产品形态，
它和中国人对食物的审美。
背道而驰，
中国人对食物的审美是什么，
我说一个歌，
你们脑补出BJM，
左手一只鸡，
右手一只鸭，
中国人对食物的审美。
是整鸡，整鸭，整鱼，
一定要是全须全尾，
牛排就得是圆切牛排，
牛肉饼是什么，
不存在的，
汉堡王跑来跟中国人说，
我是炭烤牛排，
中国人就跟他说，
你是牛肉饼，
炭烤不重要，
把你那个牛肉饼拿开，
你就是个快餐，
我老公之前采购了。
一批很贵的牛排，
结果发现是牛肉饼，
我当时的体感，
就是鸽给我吃汉堡堡，
就是那种感受，
我觉得这是中国人天生的，
就是喜欢圆切一大块的东西，
对，我觉得这个是代炮茶，
这个形态最大的问题，
但是它不切又没折，
因为像我们也会做一些品质代炮，
代炮线占我们整体产品的，
就出货量和出货金额的比重，
都只有不到百分之二十，
但是我们在做代炮这个事情上面，
觉得第一肯定还是要做的，
因为现在人还是要解决方便这个问题，
第二我们的代炮，
它都有对应的原业线产品，
所以消费者不容易怀疑它的品质，
它会知道说，
我在家有空，
我能完整的享受一道茶的时间，
我就去泡原业茶，
我出门在外，
今天出去开会，
我出去旅游，
我出去露营，
我不大可能以那种方式喝茶了，
对吧,
那我拎个代炮走，
我可以冷泡，
我也可以扔进保温杯里面，
怎么着都可以，
所以什么场景下，
中国消费者会选择代炮，
有便携性需求，
压过了品质需求的场景，
他才会捏着鼻子，
将就着喝一喝，
大概就是这些场景，
办公室酒店出差户外，
对,
你既然来客人，
你要上个代炮茶，
估计人家，
真的就是做五分钟就要走人那种，
你是不欢迎我吗？
对，牛肉碎一做的饼，
你当个早饭吃，
就快速吃一餐可以，
家里来个客人，
你煎牛排一个人，
端着一个牛肉饼出去，
就感觉好像不大对头，
对,
这个角度很有意思，
以前从来没想过这个事情。
但其实立顿很冤，
你知道吧，
立顿在严格意义上，
并不是中国人认为的碎茶，
就是中国人认为的碎茶，
是像牛肉碎，
牛肉末那种，
是边角料，
立顿还真是用完整的茶叶做的，
只不过，
他在发酵这个过程当中，
把茶进行了揉切，
这个东西，
立顿和中国人，
就是完全对不上眼神，
就是,
完全对不上眼神，
因为这个东西，
不是给中国人做的，
立顿之所以这么处理，
是因为西方人的喝茶形式，
就是要加糖加奶加柠檬，
且他需要一次性萃出，
中国人是分断萃取，
原业之所以，
对于分断萃取重要就在于，
他会让物质一道一道，
慢慢吸出，
而西方人的喝茶方式，
它是要一次性取出，
越浓越好，
因为你如果茶汤不够浓，
以前是没有像现在这样的冰博客，
以及5.0足够浓的，
把水抽掉的牛奶的，
以前的牛奶，
就是从牛那挤出来，
啥样就是啥样，
最早是觉得3.8都已经很好了，
蛋白质含量，对不对，
当你奶不能加浓的时候，
喝奶茶，
口感要好，
要醇厚，
那你就只能茶底越浓越好，
立顿是匹配西方喝醇厚奶茶，
需求所诞生的茶尘品，
它不是给中国人，
啥也不加，
只凭茶与水，
就有完全风味，
还要一段一段，
分段萃取做的产品，
所以立顿的产品在国内卖不好，
那太正常了，
它完全和这个市场不匹配好吗，
它PMF完全不成立，
而且很多喝茶的人，
还要讲究调索，
还要观行，
对你这个切碎了我怎么看，
这个就是有问题的，
但这个是上一代了，
这一代消费者，
也没有那么的看这件事情，
但确实就是中国人对于，
整鸡整鸭整鱼，
是有很强的执念的，
我听立顿那边说，
他们有一阵卖的最好的，
其实也不是原业茶，
而是那个奶茶，
我不知道你们有没有印象，
他们还找徐静雷带颜啥的，
立顿奶茶是吧，
对，包括茶里卖的最好的，
也是口味茶嘛，
像那个蜜桃乌龙那些，
都不是正儿八经的茶叶，
对的,
中国消费者也不认为，
他们是做纯茶的品牌，
就是中国消费者可能觉得，
这些树叶都比他们，
更接近于做中国茶的品牌，
对，茶里出过高端的黑标产品，
我喝过，茶叶相对来讲，
就比较整了，
有点类似于，
像我们说原业茶的概念，
拆盖包装的确里面的东西还不错，
但是问题是卖的很差，
因为大家接受不了，
当时他们做过尝试这件事情，
茶里做这件事情没有优势，
成本和品质的优势都没有，
品牌形象的优势也没有，
就他们做不起来也很真诚，
对，我觉得品牌上面的联想，
我觉得不成立，
因为它起家都是靠这种，
所谓的风味茶起家的，
你现在回头去做原业茶，
其实对于用户来讲，
就是人群完全是两个不同的人群，
风味茶的人群是不是理论上，
就是如果真喜欢茶的口味的饮料，
早就被奶茶用户给抢走了呀，
它跟奶茶还是有共性也有差异，
共性的地方，
就都是会在口味上面追求的更强一点，
不同的地方是，
人们对饮品的需求还是会分成，
要喝清淡口的和要喝浓郁口的，
比如说蜜桃乌龙，
覆盖的人群就是又要喝清淡口，
最好是灵堂灵卡，
又希望它有点味道，
这个味道最好还比较抓人，
基本上是这样一群人，
我们从茶圈往外走一走，
就是所有的破圈型的产品，
蜜桃乌龙肯定算一个碎银子，
洗茶出过碎银子嘛，
诺香风味的，
包括小青干，
中方树叶的前两大单品，
青干葡萄，
第二就是茉莉花茶，
这几个啊，
蜜桃，诺香，
青干，茉莉，
它的共性透针式，
它的风味都很突出，
非常的抓人，
茶里在那个时候拥有蜜桃乌龙，
这只产品还是，
实业命也运也，
非常幸运的一件事情，
因为那个时候，
这些风味算是破圈风味，
也就是大众风味，
大众风味最需要匹配什么，
匹配大众渠道，
那个时候是李家麒和威亚，
他们还比较火的时候，
茶里的蜜桃乌龙，
塞进了这鸽和解的渠道里面，
所以一下子亮就走得很大，
所以茶里在鼎盛时期，
蜜桃乌龙这个单品。
和李家麒、威亚这样的大主播渠道，
对他们的消失额占比，
是非常非常高的，
但是幸运它不是常态，
流行的另外一面是它一定会过时，
像我们的日子也很苦，
我们的日子主要是太难破圈了，
但是龙锦茶和大红袍是可以卖一位子的，
它可以比我命都长，
但是蜜桃乌龙不行。
那你看来，
觉得限制茶饮算不算茶消费啊？
不算,
我觉得东方书业算茶消费，
限制茶饮不太算，
就是因为限制茶饮，
还没有跑出一家是有，
比如说对标到咖啡、精品手冲，
或者是黑咖啡占比比较高的品牌，
还没有跑出来。
比如说我可以认Manor肯定是咖啡，
但是好像限制茶饮那几个很难说是中国茶，
就是它的纯茶占比太低了，
而中国茶在过去一千年的标签，
都是轻易纯茶这一挂的东西，
但是你把它当成广义的茶来看呢，
好像也可以。
你第一波用户不是当时也是。
抛着洗茶的用户，
把他们做消费的升级吗？
我们第一波用户很好玩，
我们第一波用户当时在微信头，
朋友圈的广告，
我们第一波用户是。
星巴克、瑞信，还有洗茶，小程序，
点单用户，
把这群人洗了一遍，
为给我们发现转化率很好。
我们转化星巴克和瑞信的用户。
是转的最好的，
然后洗茶用户是高龄洗茶用户，
就是年龄比较高了，
果糖代谢有点压力了，
就是这群人。
就是我这种中年老登啊？
也不是，还要再年轻点，
30左右吧，是吧？
一般来说28岁开始吧，
28到30是开始想要。
喝一下原业茶的时候，
30到35基本上就是他们。
比较兴趣、昂然，
重度探索的时候，
一般到35到40就差不多。
有谱了，都已经。
其实现在他们有一种说法，
说东方树叶也好，
三德丽也好，
证明了国内用户对。
无糖茶的接受程度是很高的，
你认同吗？
中国人一直都很接受无糖茶，
接受了1000年了，
这不是一个问题。
从陆雨那个年代开始，
无糖茶开始占上风的分界线，
就陆有一个中国茶文化史上的名言，
说以前的人喝茶往里加盐，
加橘皮，
加干草，
加花椒，
那就会让茶喝起来，
向沟渠沸水，
陆雨认为只加盐就好了，
但是宋朝人就会觉得，
陆雨你肯定没有喝过好东西，
盐也不用加的呀，
为什么要加盐？
到明清到现在，
其实中国人喝的茶一直都是无糖茶，
但我觉得现在我们宇境里的。
东方树叶无糖茶，
它其实是无糖茶饮料，
它是饮料和茶的双生子，
它是肖锦锐，
对于饮料来说，
无糖是一个要讨论的问题，
但是对于茶来说，
它不是一个问题。
如果我们对比咖啡来说，
无糖茶其实会和黑咖有一个对比度，
除了上海人民能薛薇接受一点黑咖，
全中国人民都不太能接受黑咖的，
锐现在上海的黑咖点单率，
也就百分之十几吧，
不到二十，
对,是。
对，然后这个里面是因为。
咖啡走的是高浓郁度，
高苦度这个路线，
所以咖啡的优点是加了奶之后还是很香，
因为它高浓郁度，
缺点是黑咖真的难以下咽啊，
因为它高苦啊。
所有小红树种草里面告诉你的，
什么高香不苦，
什么咖啡油脂浓郁，
什么奶油香煎裹香，
不用相信拿到手艺喝都苦，
就没折。
因为咖啡因能度太高了。
对，然后茶就没有咖啡那么张扬，
就茶的咖啡因其实比咖啡还要再多两倍，
东方树叶的用户就肯定会分化，
一部分它就是纯饮料用户，
另外一部分它是浅粒的纯茶用户，
浅粒的原液茶用户。
有一次和我们一个客户聊天，
他们买我们陈皮波尔买了十几盒，
就说觉得和东方树叶的那个波尔很像，
饮料它有的时候没有那么方便啦，
就你一箱一箱的往办公室扛它泪的慌，
但你扔几克到杯子里面，
然后一泡就行了，
它有的时候相比于东方树叶还是更方便的，
到底是饮料更方便，还是茶叶更方便，
它要看情况。
看场景。
对，所以这里我要扔一个暴论，
原液茶它不是对标咖啡豆的，
它应该对标素容咖啡粉，
一冲就行，有水一冲就行，
它没有那么难泡，
如果你觉得农了，
你就水多加面面多加水，
你就西式就完事了，
它的宽容度比咖啡手冲要高很多。
是，我咖啡学一周，
还只入了个门。
对，就是很多茶你是可以乱泡的，
尤其是像老白茶、波尔熟茶，
你用保温杯泡都没问题。
那咖啡可不行，
咖啡都是精确到温度的。
对，咖啡完全不行，
所以不加糖的纯茶，
肯定比咖啡手冲也好，
还是咖啡自己再买个意识机也好，
它的门槛要低很多，
所以它一定是对标素容咖啡粉的，
它不对标咖啡豆，
所以不能用咖啡豆不流行来去论证说。
原液茶不流行，
原液茶比咖啡豆咖好多了。
在咖啡的消费当中，
线膜或者是这种开盖基因。
一定是占绝对比例的，
但是在茶的消费当中，
茶叶的占比还是会高的。
那比如说，
其实东方树叶大家都说。
是经历了很多年的沉寂才活起来的吗？
这个有帮你在教育市场吗？
有一点，但不多，
我们的很多市场还是得自己教育。
一个消费者从喝东方树叶到他会开始。
和一些稍微贵一点的品质茶。
他还是有一个探索的过程的，
那这个过程绝大部分还是。
我们自己需要去对消费者做引导的。
所以我们才会做很多的补贴。
去做适合营。
我们那天算完账，
发现我们五年来在消费者买适合包。
然后跟我们一起每天喝打卡，反款，
我们累计反了一千多万出去了。
夏郑老师前面说过茶其实很像香水嘛，
包括味觉类的东西，
它很难分享，也很难描述，
它更多的是一种个人的体验。
所以其实我能理解一面。
现在在做这种适应的状态，
你去跟诱惑描述这种茶多好喝，
听的人感受非常微弱，
真的不如他一口茶汤下去的感受。
就是那一瞬间喜欢或者不喜欢，很清楚。
而且这种体验很私人，
可能一款茶我觉得好喝，你觉得不好喝。
对，就是百人百味嘛。
它很像是衣服，你穿薄熙米亚风没问题，
那我不想。
那我问个问题，
就是虽然说咖啡能度不高，
为什么我喝某些奶茶，
包括我看很多网上，
之前上过日的搜，
就是喝某款茶味浓的奶茶的时候，
我们真的睡不着觉啊。
谁告诉你咖啡能度不高，
茶在同客众下，
咖啡的含量是咖啡的两倍到三倍。
我们真正讨论的是，
茶汤的咖啡能度高还是不高，
茶在什么情况下还好，
就是你保持叶片的完整，
并且分段萃取，
它的茶汤咖啡能度不高，
比如说5-8克的茶，
我们往往可以萃取1.5升，
最多最多我可以萃到2升的茶汤，
它分散进去，而且是分段萃取，
你这不就缓适了吗，对吧，
你单泡的影响，
你不会觉得体感上面很不舒服的，
但是像很多的奶茶品牌，
它为了出卑比较快速，
它用的是磨碎之后进萃茶机，
那么它的碎再加含量高，
再加高温高压，
尽可能的让它吸出了，
再加它们为了让茶底再有很多的奶和糖的情况下面，
茶味还要明显，
所以它的茶的量加的很高，
它加的可不是5克，也不是8克，是12克，
12克茶，2-3倍的咖啡因含量，
相比于咖啡豆，
那它我们换算成咖啡豆等于多少，
24-36克咖啡，
你不会单四喝36克咖啡吧，
我们一般都是15克左右呀，一杯，
对呀，对不着叫太正常了，
因为咖啡因本身是一个双刃剑，
你适量的时候，
它可以激发你的去甲身上线素，
让你提神，让你精神集中，
让你相对比较亢奋，
但是它过量以后，
它会形成阶段反应，
甚至会让你产生过度亢奋，
这个当然跟每个人耐受性不一样，
所以有些人喝了奶茶，
可能问题不大团块奶茶，
有些人喝了就会整碗睡不着觉，
就是它的耐受性相对弱一些，
所以奶茶还真的是强沉引性，
因为是糖沉引加咖啡因沉引，
再可能带点脂肪，
一大杯糖油咖啡混合物，
各种沉引性的东西混在一起，
对，所以确实奶茶生意真是个好生意，是吧？
从心理机智上来说，
胭酒茶，咖啡这几个都差不多，
是吧，沉引性的都是？
我觉得不大一样，
比如说之前我融资的时候，
所有的投资人都会问我说，
茶也不是一个很强的沉引性饮品，
头咖啡的逻辑在头茶上面肯定是不成立的，
这个点我觉得从成分的沉引性上面来说，
是的，比如说酒精或者是泥骨丁，
它的沉引性要强得多，
当然沉引性这个话好像也是骂人的，
就有在投资品类的时候，
它才是夸人的，是吧？
那固执可不是一般的不一样啊！
但是我觉得就茶的沉引性，
它并不只像某一个成分，
它只像一种综合感受，
它会让人心里比较愉快，
它是世界前时的健康饮品，
所以你会觉得，
如果我一定要对一个东西沉引，
这个东西最好是健康一点，
我心里能好瘦一点，
我觉得茶的沉引性，
它是一个综合感受，
它是一个风味，
加体感，
加场景触发，
加生活习惯，
它最后得到的结论，
就是有相当一部分人吧，
他们最后入坑了，
他入坑之后，
他会高频喝茶的，
而如果他没有入坑，
他就是把当一个饮品来喝，
那他就不会，
比如说，
我说我们现在最核心的消费者，
他年均都是十几单，
他就是典型的入坑的消费者，
那没有入坑的消费者是什么样子呢？
比如说我们代泡茶产品线，
现在夏天又是喝冷泡的时候，
我其实会经常抽茶订单，
我会发现我们有一群消费者，
24年、25年、26年，
每年过来买个两百多块钱，
买个五六盒茶包，
然后大概就是五六十包，
就差不多够他两天喝一包，
可以喝四个月，
大概这个样子，
这群人就是典型的把茶当成饮品，
无糖茶饮料，
来去喝的一群人，
陈饮不陈饮，
其实就要看他，
有没有进入到这个风味，
加体感，
加场景触发，
加生活习惯的，
这个循环当中去，
我不冲一点点，
因为我平时比较无聊，
我专门研究过关于。
茶至上饮这件事情，
我同意夏郑老师的说法，
茶跟烟酒，
包括咖啡，
其实是不太一样的东西，
烟酒咖啡本质上饮，
是因为阶段反应，
就是你不喝，你会很难受，
但茶其实比较综合，
茶安酸这个东西，
本身它其实可以安抚我们的情绪，
因为它会降低我们的皮质成分泌，
但是它的降低程度，
没有烟酒那么激烈，
所以大家喝茶的时候，
会感觉人比较安静舒服的感觉，
其实是茶安酸在发挥作用，
喝茶的过程中，
是有咖啡因吸出的，
大家讲中泡的手法要快，
就五秒出汤，为什么？
是因为你在那个过程中，
要控制咖啡因的分泌，
否则你的喝池的口感没那么好，
而且你需要通过热水去激发。
茶安酸的分泌和方向物质的分泌，
所以你闻起来的那种风味会特别好，
不同的茶，
它是在闻茶香，
去体验不同的口感，
这个时候它对应的，
是我们传统意义上的，
像咖啡因所导致的阶段反应，
而是一种对于多巴胺的诉求，
所以你会发现，
常喝茶的人，
他是不太固定喝某种茶的，
他喜欢喝各种各样，
奇奇怪怪甚至很小众的茶，
这本质上是一种多巴胺在驱动。
我们有一些茶友社群文化，
比如说翻牌子，
像皇上选妃一样喝茶，
像海王一样喝茶，
每天跟着心情翻不同的牌子，
他们甚至做了一个民间小程序，
就是把一念的茶都堆进去，
然后每天就在那抽出来什么喝什么。
而且茶圈还有很有意思的事情，
如果有人发现了某一种，
特别小众的茶，
他觉得特别好，
他推荐给别人说，
油饭只要是茶圈的人，
大家都会想办法去试一下，
哪怕去搞到一泡都可以，
就是他会有这种强烈的。
驱动说，
哎，我要试一下的感觉。
这个东西其实不是阶段反应，
它是多巴胺在分泌，
所以它的诚意性，
更趋向于正向。
这是茶圈的喇叭布，是吧？
对，茶圈的喇叭布，
就是你一定要有。
对，它作为兴趣性消费的那一面，
就跟收集喇叭布，
已经买AGA是一样的，
你一定要有一面强。
说起这个，我好奇，
我有一阵子感觉，
很流行拍卖什么普尔查案那些的，
这种东西到底是怎么炒起来的呀？
因为我感觉这个价格，
一会儿什么上到百万，
一会儿现在好像又跌得很惨。
这个就是典型的圈层文化吗？
这个话题最近出现，
是和老登经济崩盘连到一起出现的。
拍卖普尔查是从一个很有众草力的话，
叫做能喝的古董。
你品一品这个话，
古董一般拿来欣赏，
就已经觉得他很了不起了，对吧？
但是哥们今天就把他喝了，
你觉不觉得这个人很好？
普尔查从越沉越香，
然后去发掘他的老茶的价值，
就这个故事可以说是整个茶行业在过去。
二、三十年所创造出来的一个最大，
最有高度，
但也走完了一整个生命周期的叙事，
非常了不起，
但是这个叙事基本上走完了。
那给我们展开讲讲发生了什么吗？
普尔查他真的很搞笑啊，
当我们说普尔查的时候，
你甚至不知道我再说，
普尔生茶还是普尔树茶？
不懂。
从半生的顺序开始，
是先有普尔生茶的，
普尔树茶其实很晚才被发明出来，
可能要到70年代末期才有普尔树茶，
老茶的普尔茶，
就民国时代的这些普尔茶，
民国时候的这批藏家群体，
在香港是有人在收藏的，
香港回归前夕有一批人就抛盘，
这个抛盘抛到了谁手上呢？
抛到了台湾人手上。
当时又正好是台湾经济不错的那段时间，
就亚洲四小龙那段时间。
所以香港台湾的那群先富起来的华人，
就开始玩普尔茶。
玩着玩着你就肯定想要去溯源嘛。
前中叔说你吃鸡蛋觉得好吃，
你不一定非要认识那个母鸡，
但这么说之所以是一个经济，
就在于大部分时候你是想要认识那只母鸡的。
所以这群台湾的茶人，
他们就跟着普尔茶上面有一个内飞，
就是茶柄的柄纸里面有一个小标贴，
上面就写了义武阵山，
然后他们就查狂查这个义武阵山到底在哪里，
然后最后搜到了一个云南的小的阵子。
他们就飞机转火车，火车转汽车，
汽车转驴车去到了那个村里。
过去了之后就发现，
哇当地已经没有人在做茶了，
当地的原材料都是送到上一集的国营茶厂里面去做普尔叔茶，
已经没有人会做他们拿过来的那个圆饼紧押的普尔茶了。
根据他们手上的那些老茶来去复原出普尔茶的工艺，
这才有了普尔的气质饼，
所以这是一个很让人感动，
带一点艰辛，带一点执着，带一点两岸爱茶人的共同的心愿，
然后最后把它复原出来的这么的一个故事。
你觉得这个叙事没有一个伟大的品牌来承接，
真的是有点太可惜了。
对呀。
但就是没有。
我还听说是那个张国力还捐了一张汽子饼，
最后在老舍茶馆拍出了160万。
真的，就是有一种很强烈的文化询根，
然后最后把已经流失的文化又重新复原起来。
所以金融化这个事儿就是从普尔茶开始的。
金融化这个事情是，我觉得它跟茶都没有关系，
我觉得这玩意它属于P2P你知道吧。
你想有一个人跑来跟你说，
你看这个饼它又大又圆，
它有一个长得跟它很像的东西，
在加德拍卖曾经拍出过几百万，
但是我手上这个你别管它是不是，
你就说它像不像吧，
然后我告诉你，
明年我会回购这个饼加15%，
15%年利率啊。
嗯。
这什么年代啊？
有15%年利率的上市公司有几家呀。
大家给你拍胸口，
说明年我涨价15%回购，
你现在买不买？
买。
谁跟钱过不去呢？
这个人他爱不爱茶，他没有关系，
这就是他的一个金融标定物。
这个事情他就是因为普尔茶的百年传说，
普尔茶上拍卖会，
普尔茶从一片无人问津的树叶变成，
很多的创复神话，
他当然也就被一些完全搞P2P游戏的人。
作为了他们的道具，
所以我觉得这件事情跟茶都没有关系。
只是刚好比如说茶，
你完全分不清楚一百万的茶跟一万的茶，
有什么区别对吧？
对啊，就这个螃蟹片局国外有一个版本，
是养牛你应该听过，你听过吗？
没有啊。
他说你可以给我多少钱，
然后我在澳洲的养牛厂，
帮你养一头牛，
对，然后他长大了之后，
就可以变成更多的钱，
然后你到时候可以变现，
结果就有很多人买进来，
就是为了卖出嘛，
但是突然有朝一日，
他的收割就是告诉你，
所有的牛我都已经宰了，
我现在有一千斤牛肉，
牛肉你要不要啊？
这个其实吵的是一种，
基于某一个标的物的大家未来，
长假的共识。
对,就P2P。
在普尔茶发展的历史当中，
是一个里程碑一样的世界，
叫做马队进京，
从古六大茶山，
然后他们访茶马古道的，
马队的马帮的形式，
駝着好不容易復原出来的普尔茶，
然后一路走，
纯走，啊当然是马走啊，
马走人也走，
一路走，
从云南走到北京，
最后走到北京的马连道，
然后再把央视低落窝来做个，
采访啥的，
在那个年代，
在报刊家，
电视台的年代，
哇，瞬间就变成了大新闻。
这就史多普尔茶，
从完全无人问津，
编吹小镇，
默默无闻，
这样一个选手，
一下子变成，
全国主目，
各种传说，
就差黄泡加深。
你觉得这有一点，
相当的夫人，
他们当时的有一些味道，
就是自己给自己制造传奇，
然后抓码，
然后聚光灯。
巨大的事件影响啊？
对。
而且我感觉，
整个茶马古道都被带火了，
就是连地方旅游都被带起来了。
我有一个很喜欢的，
一个博主，
叫老九，
估计夏长老师有个人也知道，
他里面有句名言说，
没有一本山海经，
你都不好意思说，
自己是卖普尔的，
就有这里面，
很能抓码的事情。
对,
中国人做事情，
太喜欢往上找了，
只要往上找，
你一定能够找到一个出处。
就是特别搞笑，
我们之前在，
做一只花椒风味的饮品，
就花椒青砖，
最早是我自己选品的时候看到了，
我觉得特别好，
然后后来再给花椒入茶，
找出处，
然后发现从汉代到唐代，
中国人喝茶，
就是往里面加花椒的。
这事让我觉得，
中国就是历史足够长，
常试过的路径足够多，
你就往上找吧，
你一定能找到。
你们还经常听到一句话，
叫做,
神农长白草，
玉七十二毒，
得茶而解，
然后说茶是百病之药，
这个传说你们听过没有？
听过，听过。
对,
这个课真的，
我觉得也特别好玩，
我前两年在浙大上课嘛，
然后,
这个课我以前是不信的，
我在浙大读书的时候，
王岳飞老师，
是中国茶申请世界文化遗产的，
主要推动者之一，
然后他的PPT，
就是从这句话开始的，
我当时都愣了，
我说,
这还能用科学的方式，
原上吗？
后来发现了，
喝，还真是，
他的那个理论是说，
茶的核心的成分，
包括茶酸，
包括茶多分，
尤其是多分，
是最好的，
天然抗氧化剂之一，
这个科艾瑞斯就应该，
很熟悉了，
美妆品牌天天都在聊，
抗氧化，抗氧化，
而且是口福宝剑，
口福美容。
说不定以后直播间说，
我快四十了，
你就麦可好了，
你确实看着很嫩，
从他们的角度上面来看，
就会觉得，
如果所有的毛病都可以，
追溯到端利体的氧化，
我自己也经常查论我，
然后就发现，
茶这个也有用，
茶那个也有用，
特别好笑。
那我们回到你，
现在就是为什么，
会选择做，
一念这么相对，
比较小众的赛道，
就是你做的时候，
也没想到，
他这么小众呀，
遇孤过难度，
还是低估了难度，
当时我们创业的时候，
是二一年嘛，
那还是新消费的尾巴，
那那个时候，
对我的前老板就跟我说，
你要是要创业，
就现在赶紧，
你再不创业，
这个周期就过去了，
你就四十岁见，
我说那行吧，
那要不还是干了吧。
所以当时会觉得，
对消费创业来说，
肯定是不输不做，
那我确实也不热爱美妆，
那我就只能去做点，
我相对热爱的事情，
当时看茶，
已经看到说，
他有这样或者那样的问题，
最大的问题，
就我刚才说的，
一百万的茶商，
这个市场太碎了，
但当时我们有一个猜想，
因为当时是抖音崛起的时候嘛，
差不多二零年是抖音元年，
所以当时觉得，
中芯化的互联网流量分配逻辑下，
应该有机会拿到一些。
当年央视时代，
就是中芯化媒体，
带来的这种品牌塑造的机会，
会觉得这是一个比较大的变量，
然后再加上，
我们团队自己做
用户的运营，用户的服务，
用户满意度，
应该还是有两把刷子的，
所以当时是基于这两个变量，
觉得如果我们能够拿到中芯化的流量，
且能够用比较高粘性重服务，
长周期的方式把LTV做出来，
应该还是有机会的，
因为我们最早其实，
学瑞幸会学的多一点，
整个用户全生命周期的这一套，
这一套东西在完美日记身上，
肯定是破产的，
但是在茶品类身上，
我们觉得是有机会的。
我记得创业的话，
你刚开始的时候就跟我说，
第一是你因为自己玩，
一年花好几万，
甚至更多钱在这个上面，
觉得也采了些坑，
也知道用户的需求。
另一方面，
其实你当时就觉得这个行业是一个大市场，
但是有品类无品牌，
所以总觉得，
经过新消费这一波，
咱们都有可能把这个品类重新做一遍，
对，但后来你就发现，
唐平孙说的也对，
就如果一个地方，
他一直没有大家伙长出来，
那这个东西可能是有点硬伤的。
你以为你去了南海，
那些之所以能成为鸿海的地方，
在于他的生态养得了那么多人，
激烈的拨杀，
然后这边就属于一千万茶农，
和一百万茶商，
在做一些低水平高烈度的竞争。
所以你现在遇到最大的难处是什么呀？
区体遇到的难处就是，
消费者的信任，
在别的行业，
他落到品牌上面很容易，
在我们这个行业，
我们围绕消费者信任，
做了很多的工作，
包括品牌的打造，
包括甚至都白送十五包给消费者，
然后跟他一包一包的喝过来，
就这些努力都抵不过，
几个看起来是农民的人，
假白意思在抖音砍个架，
然后仿佛就让消费者减了个大便宜，
然后同时他们指着我们的鼻子骂我们臭肩伤，
把价格搞那么高，是吧？
就是品牌上面花的所有的成本和努力，
本来应该用来降低消费者信任的难度和门槛，
但我们扭头一看，
发现有人不用付出任何东西，
只要假白意思装一装演一演，
消费者就更信任他。
所以比如说在抖音，
或者直播间种环境很容易列币驱逐良币，
然后大家也感受不到这个中间的差异，
对，所以到23年的时候，
我不是就自己做IP号了吗？
其实这也是属实是为了降低用户沟通成本，
然后来去做的一个选择。
所以就是你必须老板自己不停地面对消费者，
让人家相信你，信任你，
之后就可能跟着你这个人买东西。
对，但是即便如此，
消费者可能也觉得那个假白意思，
装样子装出来的茶农更值得信任，
就是很无奈。
你们现在主要探索的是自用吗？
还是说比如说礼品什么的也都做呀？
感觉就是茶这个场景，
包括购买人群跟使用人群都挺分散的。
对，就是我们目前更多的是自用，
因为我们做品质茶的话，
尤其是我们用高频消费，
接近于快销的思路在做，
这也是之前更有手感的事情吗？
那如果是送礼他的评次，
还是会相对低一点，
可能一年送两次，
而且送礼的话，
他每年会付购的概率不会那么的高。
他可能今年送茶，
明年可能就送一个别的什么纪念品，
然后后年就送一个别的啥，
他不太会年年都送礼。
那每年都还有货客压力，
这个是我们当时看礼品这个需求，
对我们来说没太有诱惑力的点，
当然我后来发现了，
品质茶作为风味营品这个需求来说，
它的出众面确实会比较窄，
而礼品是一个更大众的需求，
所以小观察也好，
还是T9还是Tstone，包括一些传统茶器，
他们做礼品市场，
那确实是一个更容易在更短的时间内。
做起亮的选择。
而且我觉得礼品话是一个自然的趋势，
就像一念你们没有其实可以去做礼品话，
但是就是会有人买了，
把它当成一个伴手礼，
或者是一个礼物的形式送给别人。
其实是我们做自营起家，
所以我们包装会相对简单，
然后把内容物的成本占比给堆上去，
那它对内裙舌头很尖，
很聪明的消费者来说，
它很容易喝出我们更好，
当然这也得它是这个内幕的老用户，
它能辨别出来我们好，
然后从而形成忠诚和年兴，
对于礼品来说送礼的和收礼的，
它不是一个人，
然后很多礼品茶都不一定被喝掉，
它可能在流转的过程当中，
你送我，我送它，它送它，它送它，
最后不知道被谁喝掉了，
所以我当时入茶行业的时候，
有行业里面的老大哥跟我说，
夏哲你要知道做茶最不重要的就是口味，
因为最后都不知道被谁喝掉，
他们的成本比例更高的都是用在包装上，
所以我们听过很多行业的八卦，
某大厂，它的包裁采购的成本，
是要大过它的茶叶采购成本的，
这个不就是十年以前的月饼吗？
对，对吧？对，
其实香水也有点像呀，
你想最占钱的香水品牌在国内，
也是离品生意很大，
所以他们也是香水的成本远不如包裁成本的，
每个企业或者是品牌，
它都是挂在自己的价值之网上的，
对，你有这样的客户市场，
你就会产生这样的产品逻辑，
你就会产生这样的费笔逻辑，
你就会产生这样的供应链逻辑，
你要再做一个新市场，
你就会做出一些你原来你的东西有点矛盾的东西，
比如说我们如果要去做离品市场，
我们就得把里面的内容物的成本就得降下来，
但其实比如说我们现在产品线，入门线，
进阶线，高阶线，
我们入门线的很多品质放到别人那里，
已经是人家的中端线的东西，
那可能我们做离品市场，
我们就把我们入门线的内容物拿出去做一个更华丽的包装，
也许就够了，
但这件事情和我们自己的定价逻辑打价，
我们现在的缝附就属于不同的消费市场的产品逻辑，
它在打价，
然后你又有自己的坚持，
那你们现在就是真的要通过爱家爱户的教育吗？
因为之前我跟CK老师聊过这个事儿，
要做中国如果是像你们这种比较偏走查文化路线的，
很难的一点是CK老师这些总结说，
他觉得查文化有点像是大幅文化，
而这个中国是出现过断裂的，
所以你相当于要绕过那个断裂点，
重新把以前的旧文化蓄上，
这个教育工程是很复杂的。
我觉得这还不是我们现在最要解决的问题，
我们现在最要解决的问题是我们在品牌的前几年，
花在产品体系和品牌搭建上的功夫，
功夫有点太多了，然后对渠道反而不是太重视。
这个里面有客观原因，有主观原因，
就我自己回顾相对客观一点的原因是查这个行业，
它确实社会分工程度很低，
但它又横跨了第一产业，第二产业，第三产业，
所以一个企业要从头干到尾，
就比如说你做美妆，
你可以找博主做种草，
但是我做查的话没有什么查博主，
查博主都自己做货去了。
所以我们就必须往前，
我们也没有什么大的供应商能解决，
外面日记前辈人嘲笑说他是科斯美斯的搬运工，
我们没有科斯美斯，
比如说我们现在60多个SKU，
我们是每一个在做源头直采，
直采到什么程度，直采到农民供销社，
能直采到茶厂都不错了，
我们有很多品牌是对到供销社的，
你能想象美妆企业，
做一罐面霜，
它要先从辱入果原料采购开始干，
我记得我有次说我在北京约你，
你说不行，我这段时间都在田里，
就爱家爱户农民那儿收茶呢，
我当时就惊呆了，
他说我合着以为是做个电商，
没想到再做农业，
好像就二年的时候吧，
真的，我都觉得如果再过个十几二十年，
我要是重新杀毁美妆行业，
我就把什么云南千年古茶树的什么茶果，
拿来炸油，
然后做个面妆卖给美妆用户，
应该能卖的不错，
我觉得，
我现在这是供应链在手，
你们还要找原料商，
俺就是原料商，
淡完你对茶的品质有点要求，
那么意味着你这条线就不能放心的交给别人去做，
你从头就一定要做到位，
所以现在买你们的人都是年轻人吗？
看你怎么定义年轻了，
我觉得30到40整体都还挺年轻的，
那是必须把我放在里边，
因为中国的老龄化，
30到40的人显得很年轻，
这个国家的年龄中位数，对吧？
对，因为一般说起喝茶，
感觉还是挺灯的，
但我感觉好像你们的用户，
应该相对来说还是年轻一些，
相对年轻，
但是没有那么年轻，
还是核心用户在35岁，
上下5岁吧，
就30到40这个年龄层，
就80后90后，
马上00后也要进入到我们的。
目标用户范围了，
不敢想啊，
2000年的人今年26了，
00后马上步入30，
不过你们这个行业，
其实如果老龄化趋势是好的，
反而对你们是好事，
后面这几十年都是喝茶的，
喝茶这个习惯，
它就是得喝一辈子，
所以我们的基本盘用户。
还是非常稳健的，
核心解决的就是让更多的用户。
可以更容易的进入到我们的怀抱吧，
因为我关注一年其实时间也比较久，
我有几个问题想问一下，
第一个问题，一般我们看茶，
看各种各样的茶产品，
大家都是以产品命名的，
比如什么西湖龙镜，
然后什么老寿梅啊，
振山小种啊，或者是什么，
但是一念的命名其实挺特别的，
你们会起一些跟茶。
其实没有太大相关的名字，
这个从沟通效率上来讲，
我觉得是有些影响的，
但你们为什么要这么做呢？
就从纯感性的角度啊，
你们有家里养宠物的吗？
养啊,
你会给宠物起名字吗？
对,
喜欢名字你会觉得它不是一个路边的小猫小狗，
而是就像一个人一样，
这个里面做了非常多的牺牲，
尤其是前期，
就我们前期为了让用户。
更记住品牌独特性，
其实我们品类名都是不透出的，
后期我们会同时在产品上透出产品名和品类名，
这样的好处，
就像你刚才说的在外部去搜索品类名的时候，
这个东西能够被搜到，
但我们还是非常坚持，
一定要给它一个产品名，
原因是我觉得对于品类的新用户来说，
它也不知道这个品类名，
所以产品名和品类名对它的沟通效率其实是一样的，
新人对吧？
它其实并不知道老寿媒和东方美人到底是什么，
有什么不一样，
并且即便是对于一些老茶客来说，
品类名的沟通效率在非标行业不见得高，
因为当我们在说龙警察的时候，
我们可能在聊的是九块九的龙警察，
两百一斤的龙警察，
一万一斤的龙警察，
它都叫龙警察，
如果你要把它区分开来，
你要给它非常多的限定，
这是二零二六年的西湖产区的，
施风产区的，
翁家山这个国理产区的，
民前的投采的群体种的龙警，
当你有这么多限定词加下去的时候，
这个沟通效率已经不高了，
对，所以就会产生，
比如说像最近二十年，
金居媒是一个被捧起来的新的，
制裁公益的新品类吧，算新品类，
但最后你就会发现全世界都是金居媒，
它脱离金居媒的标准已经非常远了，
所以我觉得一念最早在产品上面想做的，
就这个是纯理性方面，
我们希望有一个极具辨识度的风味，
这个风味落到一个独特的名字上，
至于中间是什么原料，
什么工艺，
唐贵消费者不需要了解的那么细，
它只需要记住这个风味，
记住它的平营体验，
然后记住这个名字结束，
这就会说回来品牌的愿景，
或者品牌的出发点，
我们在2021年起步来去做这个品牌的时候，
我们心很野，
我们当时想的是，
心里的那个最初的愿景是，
想要重塑中国人和茶相遇那一瞬间的体验，
就是我们不想让中国消费者再从西湖产区的。
尸丰的、翁家山的、
民前特彩的群体种农界，
开始了解中国茶，
我们会希望大家可以从风味的、体验的，
以及文化想象的这个层面来去理解中国茶，
这是一个类似于创世纪一样的工作，
所以它真的很难，真的很难。
所以你当时算是自断双臂，
对吧?
就是我把所有大家默认的那些东西先去掉，
让大家以一念为入口去了解茶。
真的,
而且我一个销售老大出身的人，
我已经五年没有干过销售了。
我感觉他在重新建立一套新的启发视频键，
这个其实是一件很难的事情。
是的,
所以我们很多自己的茶友，
到最后他们会觉得，
看着那一墙壁的一念的不同的茶，
他们会觉得这是一个世界，
就真的是一个创世纪的工作，
一念宇宙。
因为每一款茶，
它一看过去都有非常深刻的内涵在里面。
对,
我觉得像打开一个故事包一样，
你们每次发一个故事包过来，
然后解压缩之后里面就是有图，
有故事，有内容，有风味，
还挺好玩的对于我们以前不喝茶的人。
而且中国的语言啊，
中文啊，
它真的是诗一样的语言，
它足够的模糊，
所以它足够的包容，
它也有足够多的想象，
在里面。
比如说我们有一款老白茶叫红炉硬血，
这款茶，
它的名字就会给你这样的氛围感，
你就应该在一个静静的厅窗外的雪落下，
然后深一个火，
开始孤独孤独的煮它，
煮出来非常温暖的，
纵红色的茶汤，
然后一口下去，
纵叶和红枣的香气，
把你包裹起来，
你觉得哇，
这就是这个时候我应该有的体验。
虽然是夏天，好有意境啊。
我问一下红炉硬血，
意境是曲自白俱义的问刘时久？
对,
因为恰好我很喜欢这种事。
可太有文化了。
我们还有一只普尔茶，
它是叫晚晴山光，
包括万色风。
都是因为名字好听买的？
对，因为整个云南，
它就是横断山脉，
山和它的水重重叠叠的，
被挤压到一起形成了。
高地落差很大的大地的折咒。
那就是万鹤风来啊，
风从这些山挤出来的缝隙，
这些河流批开的缝隙当中穿过，
你就会有这种感受，
就是我们会想要把很多在地文化的，
风味的，
这些人文密码去揉到一杯茶当中，
所以一杯茶当中，
承载的信息量是很大的。
而我们也当然知道，
这个事情在刚一打照面的那个瞬间，
不会让消费者一下子全部都理解到，
但我们会希望它更耐品一点。
你看更耐品一点，
这个话是非常中国茶的，
因为中国茶不是一影而尽，
它是陪伴式的，
你要一道一道一道的去喝它，
每一道的滋味还会有不一样，
所以我们更像是在每一个产品那里，
打包了一整个有滋有味的信息包进去，
让消费者可以慢慢的拒绝，
然后每次都有新的发现，
一盒茶50克，
它可能要喝10次，
能把它喝完，
那如果我们这个产品能让消费者。
每一次喝它都有新的体会和感受，
那我们应该做得还蛮棒的。
这是我们很想要去创造的，
消费者和中国茶相遇的初体验，
以及消费者在探寻中国茶的过程当中，
那个取尽通忧一步换解，
每一次都有新的领悟的体验，
也是我们想要去创造的，
就我们的想要的东西有点太多了，
这也是我对自己过去五年。
做的很多事情的一个反思吧，
但是反思完也觉得好像没有什么可改的，
求人得人，
这就是我想要的，
所以你就接受你现在。
还是一个不太大的品牌就可以了。
我有点理解一念的复刻率为什么好了，
因为它其实做的整个一套东西，
我们讲学术点叫用户介入度很高，
我觉得这是现在很多人在苦恼，
就是白牌怎么去转品牌，
一个关键的节点，
就是你让用户就节奏放慢下来，
让用户介入进来，
它也许会影响你的成交效率没有以前那么高，
但是会让你留下来的用户对于你的印象更深，
而这种印象其实是影响到用户后面跟你的关系的，
我觉得这点其实还挺有启发的。
以及我觉得还有一个点可能是心态吧，
我们在品牌一周年的时候，
今年是第五周年了，
我们在一周年的时候，
我们的推文的名字就叫。
品牌一周年离百年老店还有九十九年。
一开始我就没有把这件事情当一个一两年的项目来干，
Iris我们都是从新消费那一波通货膨胀过来的。
通货膨胀起来的，
对，就那个时候其实很多人是把自己做的牌子当成项目来看的，
就是一二三行就行，不行就算了。
我其实没有太这么看，
我觉得如果我们把它当成一个十年的事情，
和把它当成一年的事情，
你把它当十年的事情来做也许它就成了，
你把它当一年的事情来做也许它就砸了。
这句话很对。
对，那这个时候就属于，
我其实不太怕别人来抢我们的饭碗，
因为它耐不住十年的寂寞。
就这个饭碗很难抢的。
我在听你讲的时候，
有一种巴塔哥尼亚老爷爷上升的感觉，
很少有创始人士你自己刚好就是那个死忠用户，
然后你也愿意在这个事情上沉淀一辈子。
真的是求人的人，
我觉得这五年坐下来我也还是很满足，
因为可能在别的行业，
我并没有机会去为这个行业的发展作标留下一些什么，
可能因为查行业的落后，
可能因为它的难导致很多有天赋有才华的人，
它不会进入这个行业。
碰巧我看起来像一个傻子一样就冲进来了，
还像一个傻子一样干了五年，
那我多少是会给这个行业留下点东西的，
因为在经验也好，眼界也好，
其他方面也好，
我应该还是能给这个行业带来一些新东西，
再加上也还算比较努力吧。
你说另一个比我聪明，
比我努力，比我眼界更好的人，
他真的愿意扎进来干五年吗？
他不愿意的。
肯定宁可搞金融了呀。
对呀，P2P多香啊。
我觉得主要是夏正老师内心喜欢这个事情，
所以他才能坚持下来。
而如果你把它做成一个项目，
或者是一个生意，
我觉得就说你很难坚持下来。
只当生意不会这样，
它是当孩子养的，
你看这取名就知道了。
我当时收到夏正的PPT，
我到时候也发shownotes里面，
有一句话我是特别有感触的，
他说咱们是工业巨手，
中国人是非常擅长去用物质创造这种功能的，
但是却很少有人有这个时间跟嫌弃意志，
去用情感创造意义。
那一念今天在做的事，
其实就是通过这么多年的生根，
持续在希望给这种一片片的茶叶，
各种劣币驱逐良命的环境里面，
要去创造意义，
而这个过程本身就很难。
对，而且我觉得现在，
可能时代确实有些不一样了，
因为我是90后嘛，
那我在2013年，
进入社会开始工作的时候，
当时就觉得，
就是宏打叙事，干一把大的快速增长，
博弈博单车变摩托，
很多的创业热潮，
也是那个时候开始的，
我入行比较早，
我是在双创那一波，
大众创业万众创新那一波入行的，
当时很多人会瞄着结果做事情，
我觉得当下就是属于这个增长曲线，
它就是平换了，
大家都要接受它平换了，
那我们可能要更多的去看一看，
如果你更努力一点，
并不会让你赚更多的钱，
那还有什么价值和意义，
是你想要追求的。
这里我觉得，
一是我自己内心，
还是有很多要表达的东西，
这些东西可以用内容表达，
也可以用产品和品牌表达，
做消费还是很快乐的一点，
是你可以创造出很多美好的产品，
这些美好的产品可以影响很多的大众，
数以万计，数以十万计，千万计的大众，
他们也可以和你的心念在这个瞬间，
产生一些互动和回响，
我觉得就很开心。
像我们做了一件最佳待伺候的事情，
就是我们所有的茶具，
赠品上面会印四个字，
叫做不如饮茶，
它是来源于赵州河上的一个公案，
叫做吃茶去，
不管谁去问这个产师，
他都说吃茶去，
就是不重要。
后来赵卜初先生，
就是一个很有名的局势，
他写过一首记子叫空池百千计，
不如吃茶去，
所以我们把不如饮茶印在我们所有的茶具上，
其实它是一个时代的位置，
与其焦虑不如饮茶，
与其恐惧不如饮茶，
与其不知道做什么疲惫不如饮茶，
与其跟女朋友、男朋友吵架不如饮茶，
与其生老板的气不如饮茶，
你可以在前面加任何的潜质，
但它都可以在有一些时刻安慰到你，
因为当你举起那个茶杯的时候，
它就是会让你进入到一个更放松，
又更专注的心流状态，
有的时候我觉得很奇妙，
韩茶一味，它真的是有物质基础的，
它和咖啡的文化是不一样的，
但这个文化它就很中国，
听到我好感动呀，
结尾我不得不替群友要点福利了，
其实咱群友应该都是你的目标用户，
你们有啥适合发福利，
大家一起体验体验的吗？
天呐，这是一个，
印广,
我们价值199的寻查中国，
十五口味的适合，
咱们群友只要是想体验的，
我们都可以记，
哇塞，爽翻了，
大家一定要一键三连，
一键三连的我们送，好吧？
但是就是要敬我们的茶友群，
要的，要的，要的，
主要是你群里还挺好玩的，
所有想要学用户运营的，
我觉得真的可以跟着你玩，
这个确实你是老司机，
欢迎大家想要喝茶的都来找我们，
应喝敬喝，
真的有被感动到，
我不知道大家听完啥感受，
这就是我跟CK一直在说，
可能未来的时代你不追求大而全，
但一定有很多，
特别有生命力的品牌，
在创始人的起心动念之下，
长成一个比较健康，
也比较有生命力的样子，
我觉得一念其实就是一个这样子的牌子，
所以特别希望你们越做越好，
哎呀，好感动呀，
因为我们这个样本来是挺少见的，
所以很多人看我们会觉得很好玩，
是，主要是你还从高速增长的，
很浮夸的美妆行业，
又是做私欲的，
做到这个我觉得，
跨度确实是很好玩，
笑死怎么说呢，
在每一个不挣钱的晚上都很后悔，
但是一觉醒来，
又觉得生活还是有希望的，
我又醒了，
哎，我又可以了，是吧，不如饮茶去，
嗯，就是这个行业太糟了，
但是我又醒了，
好的，那就这样，拜拜，
好的，拜拜，
拜拜,
是，大人不在家，
我们有地方一堆区，
石头，帕马手，
寄完我的世界，PVP，
是，太阳下山背海，
回家带点忧郁，
因为暑假作业，
又要写一篇周期，
Oh, Dime,。
下烂过的漫，
All the time with all my friends,。
人热的天，
依旧外面留着汗，
以前都觉得世界跟着我们转，
转呀，转，
时间过的漫，
阳光灿烂的日子，
没什么能换，
夏天跑过我的身边，
只能站在看，
寂寞小规，